Ihatetobesaying this,andIreallyhopethatI'mwrongbutwemaynowbeontheprecipiceoftheglobalrecession.
Thatweanticipatedwouldeventuallycome.Wedidn'tknowwhen,butoneoftheinherentelements
ofoursystemisthepersistentboomsandbusts.
There'salwayssomedown­turnsomerecessionaroundthecorner,wejustdon'tknowhowmany
blocks,wearefromturningthecorner,sotospeak.Rightnow,thestockmarketisopenasweare
producingtoday'sshow.
JustnineminutesinthestockmarketdroppedbysomuchintheUnitedStatesthatittriggeredsome
protectivemeasureswhichshutdown,creatingimmediatelyintheUnitedStates.
10minuteslater,stocksre­openedat9­50­A­M,EasternTime,andthestockshavebeenupand
downalldaytoday.Couldbe,couldbethegreatestsingledaydeclineinstockmarkethistoryOna
pointbasisnotonapercentagebasis,itmayreversebeforetheendoftheday,wedon'tknowbutas
ofrightnow,wecouldhavethelargestonedaypointdeclineinthehistoryofourstockmarket.In
additiontothis,theoilmarkethascrashedoilpricesfellasmuchas34%andstabilizeddownabout
03/10/20 Page4of17
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­09­commercialfree
21%.Again,asofrightnow,thisinformationmaychangebythetimeyoulistentotoday'sshow,or
watchthisclipSaudiArabiaandRussiaarenowinagrowingpricewar,thisisthemostthatoil
priceshavefallenindecades,thentheystabilizedownabout21%,andthosenumberswillcontinue
tochangeovertheweekend.Russiarefusedtosayhowmuchoiltheyareproducing.
Theywereaskedtomakesomecommitmentsinordertostabilizethemarket.Russiarefusedtosay
howmuchoilthey'reproducingSaudiArabiainresponse,thendrasticallycutprices,thiscaused
worldmarketstocrashtheUS.
Let'ssee,100indexwasdown7%,asofacoupleofhoursago,Americanstockmarketsalso
down...Andthenofcourseontopofallofthis,wehavethegrowingvirussituationwhichwehave
beencoveringextensively,andwe'llcoverlaterontoday,andIknowyouallknowaboutaswell.
Solisten,wemaybe,atthestartofamassiveglobalrecessionwhichifindeedisstartingnow,it
couldbeyearsbeforewegetbacktothepricelevelsofthestockmarketofamonthago.Now,the
stockmarketdoesn'taffecteverybodyatleastnotdirectly.Andtobeclear,Ihopeitdoesn'thappen
everytime,Itweetabouttheeconomy,Igettweetsfromfollowerswhosay,"OhDavid,you'rejust
beggingforaneconomiccrash,sothatDonaldTrumpgetspoliticallyheardaren'tyou?
Now,I'mnot,I'vemadethatclear.Idon'twantpeoplelosingtheirjobs,Idon'twantstocks
crashing,Idon'twantanyonetodiefromthevirus.I'mnotaterribleperson,soIdon'twanthorrible
thingstohappenjustsothatpeoplerealizethatDonaldTrumpisincompetent,buffoonandtobe
frank,ifyou'venotalreadyrealizedDonaldTrumpasanincompetentPeronthestockmarket
crashing,orthevirusspreadingorwhateverelseisnotgoingtoconvincethosepeople,itwouldbe
afutileeffortifthat'swhatI'mcountingonitwouldbebothmorallywrongandmisguided.Based
onthefact...WhatIwanttofocusonis,lookathowquicklythingscangointothetrashinaperiod
ofseventoeightweeksifthereisanybiggerpicturemessagehere,it'sthatoftheinherentfragility
ofoursystem.Thisispartiallyabouttheinherentnatureoftheeconomicsystemwehave,itis
fragile,we'velearnedfoodsupplylinesaremorefragilethanwethinkmarketsaremorefragilethan
wethinkthemedicalsystemisfragile.Itquicklybecomesoverwhelmedwhensomethinglikethe
virusstartstospreadventilatorsorinshortsupplyhospitalbedsareinshortsupply,panicked
peoplebymasks,theydon'tevenneedcausingashortageforhealthcareworkerswhoactuallydo
needthemforaslongasoureconomicsystemremainsfundamentallywhatitisnow,thisfragility
willalwaysexistandinfacttheboomsandthebusts?arepartofthesystem.We'vebeentalking
aboutthisforyears,asfarasthemicrowhat'sthestockmarketdoingtoday,whatistheresponseof
ourcompletelymisguidedandignorantadministrationintermsofthevirus?Wewillseehowthat
shakesouttoday,wewillseehowitshakesout,tomorrow.Ifindeedthisisthestartofaglobal
recession.Onceagain,itcouldbeyearsbeforewegetbacktothepointwherewewerejusttwo
monthsago,butforaslongasoureconomicsystemremainsfundamentallywhatitisrightnow,
thesefragilesortofawakenings,theawakeningofthefragilityofthesystemwillkeepcroppingup
becausethesystemisfragilethat'stherealitythat'snotadvocatingforpreppingthat'snot
advocatingforcommunism,it'stherealityoftheversionofthecapitalistsystemthatwehave,and
ofsomanyotherthingsthatwe'vebeentalkingaboutaswell.